dos meses antes de que Turquía acuda a
las urnas los opositores al presidente
recepta y perdogan han recibido un duro
golpe el viernes una de las principales
políticas de la oposición del país
Indicó que su partido se está
distanciando de una importante Alianza
formada para desafiar a erdogan
a estas alturas el partido bueno se ha
visto obligado a una imposición obligado
a elegir entre la muerte y la malaria
tal y como se ha hecho a la nación turca
durante años y por supuesto nos
doblegaremos ante esto
la decisión llegó cuando la fundadora y
jefa del llamado partido del bien
mercall acner anunció que no apoyaría a
quemar oglu líder del principal partido
de la oposición en su lugar ha apoyado a
otros dos candidatos mansur javas alcale
de ankara y ekrem y mamoglu alcale de
Estambul
hemos expresado nuestra opinión sobre la
candidatura de dos personas cuyos
nombres hemos oído con frecuencia en las
calles tiendas y plazas públicas durante
más de tres años son los favoritos y a
quienes hemos visto ganar al Señor
erdogan en todas las encuestas públicas
es una figura popular y ha obtenido
buenos resultados en las encuestas sin
embargo actualmente está apelando una
decisión judicial en su contra que de
confirmarse le impediría ejercer la
política juntas supondría un gran
impulso para el presidente actual cuya
popularidad se ha visto gravemente
afectada por la debilidad de la economía
y la respuesta de su gobierno al
mortífero terremoto del mes pasado